hey gq this is jack harlow and i'm going
undercover on the internet
you may not believe it but it's actually
me
[Music]
okay let's check twitter is jack harlow
the new flow
[Music]
yep if i was going to describe my flow i
would say sleek
smooth fluid uh fresh
it's fresh i play your rap every day all
day
if you don't win then that's [ __ ]
are you into
cougars inquiry minds want to know we
can teach you some things
um wow i need to tap in
i love older women i always have but yes
i am in the cougars
some girls will be four years older than
you and be like i feel like a cougar
but really 15 to 20 years older than you
and once a young man wants to touch a
smooth chest
what's the story behind jack harlow he
eminem true to the culture or is he a
vulture
hell of a question true to the culture i
grew up listening to eminem i idolized
eminem
big influence of mine growing up i mean
he's so dope but also just obviously
i remember when i was 10 or 11 i would
wear like a toboggan and hoodie and
headphones around my neck because i
wanted to feel like him
i definitely had the m m phase of
feeling like wow just that caucasian
connection
you know it's strong tick tock what's up
can you make more videos i don't know uh
maybe i'm not tapped in all the way on
tick tock yet i got three videos up
there
because it takes three to get verified
so i said all right i'll do three
knock them out i'll come back but i
heard they're spying on us so i don't
know
had to get it off my phone for real
what's popping what's five
bruh how'd you miss time your own song
my g i didn't know i missed timed it i
thought i did great actually
okay quora
[Music]
how did jack harlow become such a great
rapper at such a young age
repetition being critical hard on myself
hard on my songs
thirst hunger desire like i wouldn't
treat it like piano lessons you know
what i'm saying where it's like all
right i got to put my hour in today
because there's been times in my life
i've gone weeks without writing but
i think it just comes down to desire
like i really wanted to do this i knew i
wanted to do this with my life and
i think the whole time i've been
recording i've been getting closer to
a true version of me i think when i was
younger i was posturing a little bit
and trying to figure out how i wanted to
be and i think my self-image was a
little bit
tainted by what people thought about me
or they would tell me about me now i
feel like every year it just feels like
i'm getting closer to myself
i'm telling the truth i'm getting easier
to tell the truth but you just get to
know yourself better
ideally i think that's one of the
biggest things is people believe me more
than they did when i was younger not
that people thought i was a fraud
necessarily but there's just no cab in
my rap
what do you think makes giacarlo stand
out from other rappers i think
my music is conversational a lot of the
songs are like short stories
it's the storytelling aspect i think and
also how i look has always been a thing
how look helps is jack harlow even five
percent of the bee in bet
no he's not but a lot of people don't
know i'm actually mixed with french and
irish so
i am not any of the b and b t but i am
mixed i'm a
traditional anglo-saxon i'm mixed with
anglo and saxon
bae was your freestyle about blm
protests that freestyle definitely was
about blm brianna taylor the events that
have been going on in my hometown
louisville
it was very important and it was in my
hometown so it was hurting people really
close to me
so it was hard to go in the studio and
rap about how fly i am you know what i
mean
not only was that freestyle about that i
was making a lot of songs about that
what are the best songs of jack harlow
eastern parkway
sylvia river road warsaw
rotten ninth grade those are my go-to's
more to come though mans makes a new
tick tock every two years
that's just a good comment it's the best
comment i've seen so far well it's only
been a year so next year i'll make the
next one
now i'm joking i don't like being on the
internet that much it doesn't make me
happy
it just doesn't give me that much joy
i'm not boycotting the internet but
i delete the apps off my phone
consistently so i don't go to him so
i don't like to document my life not
constantly at least
jack made three tick tocks just to get
verified then got a point to get out of
state
actual factuals jesus people ain't
supposed to know that's what it takes to
get verified
that's hilarious that they peep at i'm
about to make another tick tock i'm
feeling some pressure
who is jack harlow it's a tough one i
don't know if i could
describe myself on camera just a wee man
let's see what instagram wants to know
wow because i feel like it's a pharrell
voice sampled on the sundown beat
it's not a pharrell voice sampled but we
got it for cheap by clips
a beat that pharrell produced when we
made sundown so much so that we had to
get permission from
pharrell himself which he obviously
granted us
it's honestly hella impressive how fast
you got that collab
you're doing great i'm here for you your
whole career thank you cheyenne
lil wayne was in a great mood every time
i got to interact with him
so he was really easy to work with it
was a dream come true for real i
remember being on set when he walked on
set and started rapping
it was an emotional moment for real i
was taken that's somebody i grew up
hearing and listened to
it's one of the goats the greatest a lot
of people's favorite ever
i felt in that moment i could just hang
my head on that moment and if i quit
today
i'd really accomplish something so i was
thrilled
all right let's see some youtube
comments
[Music]
it's honestly crazy how it's becoming
normal to be intoxicated on stage
he talked about being sober like it's
something foreign i'm glad he is
changing don't get me wrong but this
seems super normal with stage performers
in order to get confidence
last tour i went online i spent the bulk
of the tour
not drinking and i think i talked about
that in this interview
and they kind of took it as like a
recovering addict comment but i was just
talking about it
sometimes if you drink too many times
when you go on stage i think it becomes
a little bit of a crutch
you feel like oh to get my confidence to
get saucy out there
i want to drink so yeah i think a lot of
performers lean on that but that's such
an
age-old tale artist lean on something to
get in that zone everybody wants to see
the men in the
crash and burn the fact that he was able
to rap on five beats without breaking
his rhythm is crazy
all the beats are the same tempo though
so it's not as hard as people think
like they don't switch and it might as
well be the same beat but thank you for
this
i see people say that all the time and
it's not hard to catch a rhythm because
they don't change the tempo generally
let's see what's on wikipedia
throughout high school he often played
sold out shows at louisville venues like
the mercury ballroom
headliners and haymarket whiskey bar
facts
no objections i don't play at any of
those places anymore
but they're not wack venues they're
great venues but
i've graduated from those and they were
great moments for me
what up gq this is jack harlow i had a
great time going undercover on the
internet
i hope you learned something about me
peace